and the big news obviously
is
uh the vikings signing a new long
snapper no it's the tampa bay buccaneers
landing hashtag tommy from the new
england patriots it came down to the
buccaneers and the chargers brady chose
the buccaneers and you know it's been a
combination of the patriots saying
goodbye with billboards all around the
new england area but it's also been a
hello by the tampa bay buccaneers as
they land a guy and chris my goodness 25
million dollars a year on a two-year
deal the same deal that that the colts
gave to philip rivers at least the same
average for rivers it's one year 25
million for brady it's two years 50
million i mean dollar for dollar the
buccaneers got a steal
that they definitely did but i think
this continues with what we've seen from
tom brady throughout his whole career i
mean brady is just uh a selfless guy
that way and he's not worried about
always making a statement by what he's
being paid on his bank account or
whatever his you know total total salary
looks like he realizes the buccaneers
are a really good football team but they
probably need a few more pieces to kind
of finish it off and he's not looking to
lay the hammer down to go yeah i got to
make a killing here at the end of my
career and make 35 million dollars a
year no this is the great thing about
tom brady he's always been selfless like
that team first and i i really have the
ultimate respect for him doing this and
i think it's the proper thing here and
there's this narrative that is making
the rounds in some circles chris that
tom brady was insisting on control over
the offense consisting on
uh influence over the roster look i've
been told by multiple different people
that that was not the case rick stroud
of the tampa bay times had it right over
the weekend that made it clear that he
wasn't looking for that he's never been
that guy he's never had that kind of
control he's a do your job guy for 20
years when peyton manning went to denver
eight years ago he was coming from a
colts team where he did have say he did
have influence over the offense he was
basically his own offensive coordinator
so it made sense that's what he would
want when he changes teams for tom brady
he's not going to make those demands
because he's never had that he's never
done that that's not something bill
belichick's ever going to allow why
would he want to do it now and i don't
know who's pushing that angle
some suggest that maybe the raiders a
little bit disgruntled that they were
never serious finalists are kind of
throwing that idea out there to kind of
just make him look bad i don't know that
that's the case but it's not the truth
he wasn't seeking control over the
offense he wasn't seeking influence over
the roster he just wants to show up and
do his job chris
yeah well at no point did i ever believe
those bull crap rumors either it's just
not the way tom brady's wired it's not
the way he's been wired in new england
mike just you know again whether it's
through stories or my experience when i
did work there for a little bit you know
tom is the ultimate you know he's the
ultimate soldier he's going to do
whatever bill belichick or josh mcdaniel
said to do and he's going to go out
there and execute it to perfection and
while he's out there he'll be able to
coach and organize the whole team and do
all those things as well so yeah that's
not in him is he going to go in there
and want to maybe infuse a few of his
football ideas or hey here's a play i
like here's another play i like for this
situation sure but he is not peyton
manning in that way where peyton manning
would go in and basically be you know
part of the coaching staff no that's not
part of part of tom brady's dna plus he
knows he's going to a place and it
wouldn't be fair to that city at 43 to
say oh i'm gonna go in there and call
shots and then leave town two years from
now and who knows where you may be but
you know i hear it i was here and and
benefiting myself with these decisions
that wouldn't look good either that's
just not in tom brady so
i never believe those rumors
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports